one thing I wanted to ask about is I'm
really really interested in the doom of
malaria that's something that always
grabs me on really into like doom
civilizations kind of a two-part
question is there any certain story of a
doomed civilization that inspired that
for you and it's impossible that we will
ever learn any more about that well you
will learn a little more about it I
don't think I plan to write a novel
about it or anything but you know I
think every book there's a little more
and of course there's a certain amount
of it in the world of Ice and Fire and
have you seen that I haven't that I
haven't actually read all of it yet the
what inspired it you know there's
obviously the Atlantis legends are part
of it a little bit of the destruction of
the Minoan civilization which a lot of
people put in the volcanic eruption and
the destruction of the this is in
relatively recent times the destruction
of the pink and white terraces in New
Zealand and familiar with that that just
occurred in them in late 19th century
the certain area of New Zealand that was
8th wonder of the world these these
beautiful volcanic terraces tourists the
Korean tourists came and bathed in their
waters and so forth and it was one of
New Zealand's biggest tourist
attractions until one day the
surrounding volcano blew and wiped them
off the face of the earth of course in
fantasy you always turn things up to 11
or even better to 17 and so I took I
took bad and Krakatoa
and the eruption of Vesuvius and all of
these things and turned it up to 11 you
know with a few magical elements and etc
produced a beautiful area thank you hi
Robert from Newport News Virginia just
wanted to ask you about the relationship
between the Baratheon's and the
Lannister and the Targaryen because I
know the
foundation of the Bracken's is from Oris
who's half Targaryen the bastard son I
mean it seems that when magic goes from
the world the Targaryen you know fade
and then when magic and the brightness
comes to the forefront and then as magic
begins to come back the Baratheon's fade
and the Targaryen come to the forefront
so I just want to see if you could talk
about that a little bit that's a good
question and good observation you're
getting a mark the Baratheon czar are
they have a lot of Targaryen blood in
them I mean today you know not only is
the founder of the house himself a
bastard Tim to a Don the dragon but
there were they were later into
marriages and particularly you know just
a couple generations back where the
Baratheon so Roberts once you eliminate
the main Targaryen the main Targaryen
wine as they did in Robert's rebellion
Robert has the best claim to the throne
by virtue of his Targaryen blood so
there there are ties you know there are
Targaryen married brother to sister and
uncle to nice and and cousin to cousin
you know for generations to try to keep
their blood pure but sometimes they
there were no convenient siblings or
cousins around to marry and they and
they get married by necessity or in some
cases for political alliances and in
certain cases even for love with some of
the other houses of Westeros so they're
all there is part garyun blood to some
extent and not only for a Theon's put in
the Dornish and in some of the other
houses hi my name is je thank you again
for coming was to cotton my question is
with the way you have structured magic
in your world and how you just said
sometimes stories not too much magic how
do you sort
decide how fantastical to make your
fantastic creatures like such as you
have fire-breathing dragons yet your mid
to core is not the human headed tiger
the spits poison barks and little
scorpion
I don't know I just you know go with
what feels right to me dragons are cool
and you know I think that's part too
much recurrence was everyone knows what
they are manticores bachelors we know
names but not nearly as well-known as as
dragons so I have a little more freedom
to kind of this is an odd thing about
fantasy because you know coconut fantasy
where you're dealing with imaginary
lands they may seem like medieval Europe
or England but they're not middle Europe
and England so you have to decide what
feels right like you know tolki and of
course famously had potatoes in the
Shire and you know the shire otherwise
seems very much like medieval England
well what color potatoes doing there
like he obviously like his taters so he
has he has Samwise talking about how do
you want to make your rabbits with some
nice taters or something like that I
have corn in my world and it's actual
American corn it's maize it's not they
had to work corn in the ancient times of
evil but it was just a word for grain it
didn't mean maize but I like corn and it
feel wrong I don't know some readers
have complained about it so you
shouldn't have corn because it's
medieval it's not me doing one is
Westeros why can't they
[Applause]
could I have all my characters wearing
sneakers
I suppose I could but that would feel
wrong to be but you know but should I
have stirrups on the horses I know when
the stirrup was invented and how it came
about in certain periods in history if
you're wearing extreme historical
fiction you can have stirrups but when
you're reigning fantasy you can make
your decision as to whether you have it
or not so